let's solve Li code 200 number of
islands this is actually one of my
favorite problems because I feel like a
lot of graph problems build upon this
one and you can learn a lot from just
this one problem it's also a really
popular interview question a lot of big
tech companies including Google and uber
ask it so it's a good question a common
question to understand so we're given a
2d grid where ones represent land zeros
represent water we want to count the
total number of islands that exist right
and in this case an island is defined as
one's being connected and jacent ly
horizontally or vertically not
diagonally right so they have to be
connected horizontally or vertically and
the entire grid is surrounded by water
so in this example case we can see that
there's only one island right this
portion of one's and they're all
connected horizontally and vertically
and there's nothing else the rest of the
grid is just made up of water so we
don't have to look at it
so if you don't know how to solve the
problem the first thing you should do is
not try to write any code just look at
the picture and try to get as much
information as you can so think about it
how would a kid solve this problem if
you gave them the picture and told them
to count the number of islands well the
first thing you would do is notice okay
let's start at the top left hey there's
a one here right okay that means it's an
island how many other ones are connected
to this one horizontally and vertically
just by looking at it right you kind of
draw the outline there's all these ones
that are connected to each other so then
that's one island we can say that the
number of islands we have so far is one
right and if you look at the other ones
right maybe we have to count those as
well like this one but you notice it's
already a part of the island that we
drew right this outline it's already
there we're not going to count it twice
these ones are part of the same island
so the count of islands remains one and
after looking at each of these ones we'd
conclude the same thing right they're
all a part of the same island next we
could look at some of these zeros right
okay we check is this an island nope its
water
so just cross it out right don't need to
consider it anymore
is this an island nope it's water this
is water
this is water this is water this is
water this is water this is water
it's getting pretty repetitive but this
is water stillwater this is still water
but now we get to a one that means we
found another island and it's not a part
of this island that we already counted
right it's a part of a new island so
we're gonna update the number of islands
cross one out now we're gonna put two
but we have to remember that we have to
count all the ones that are connected to
this one and there's only one right
neighbor that it has right and so the
total number of islands is now two when
we get to this one again we see it's
already a part of the island that we
already counted right so we don't have
to count it again so we visited every
single cell and we concluded that the
total number of islands is two so now we
kind of have an idea of how the
algorithm works but with a difficult
part is that you might not know unless
you know a little about a little bit
about graph algorithms is how do we
actually determine this entire area
right how do we get all of the adjacent
neighbors of an island how do we mark
them as visited right let's take a look
at how we can do that so when we first
got to this one we realized we got to an
island but then we wanted to mark the
contiguous land of this island as
visited right so the first thing we
could do is say okay well the the
adjacent neighbors of this one also have
to be marked visited so its neighbors
are this one below it and this one to
the right of it okay but we're not done
yet right there could be even more ones
connected to these two that we just
visited and then we can say that for
this one below the the first one its
neighbors are this one and this one but
what about this one but above it well
it's already visited so we don't want to
mark it twice so we're not going to do
that now let's get the neighbors of this
one that was to the right of the
original one so it has one neighbor to
the right of it it also has a neighbor
below it but hey we already marked that
visited so we don't need to do that
again and then let's look at this one
and see it's neighbors well it only has
one
and then we notice that this one doesn't
have any neighbors that aren't already
visited and this one doesn't have any
neighbors that aren't already visited
either so you might already know what
this algorithm is but it's basically a
bet a breadth-first search we're just
doing a graph traversal algorithm
starting at the original point over here
and marking each layer of ones so in the
first layer we got this the second layer
we got this the third layer we got this
and the fourth layer we had just a
single value so this is really easy to
visualize and if you already know this
algorithm you can code it up pretty
quickly so knowing what we just learned
let's code it up so the first thing just
do some input validation if we had an
empty grid we don't want to have to run
our algorithm and we can simply just
return zero
there aren't any islands in that case
the next thing I like to do is just get
the dimensions of the grid so the number
of rows and the number of columns we can
get the number of rows by getting doing
this and the number of columns by doing
this we also want to be able to mark
positions or cells visited when we're
marking island masses so I'm going to
use a set to do that we could also use a
2d grid if we wanted to but I think sets
are a little easier we also want to
count the number of islands we can
initialize that as zero so we want to
visit every single position in the grid
so let's iterate through each row and
column so R is going to go through every
single row C is going to go through
every single column if we visit a zero
we don't have to do anything right but
if we visit a one then we have to do
something then we have to traverse it
and mark it visited and don't forget
that this 2d grid is actually made up of
strings not numbers that always trips me
up I think it's kind of annoying that
LICO does that but it does so now we
have to run our traversal
I'm gonna run breadth-first search
because I kind of like it so run
breadth-first search on this cell
column we also have to increment the
number of islands but remember we're
only going to be incrementing the number
of islands if we get to a one that we
haven't already visited so we're going
to make sure that if we execute this we
we've gotten to a position we haven't
visited and then ultimately we're just
going to return the number of islands
but we didn't actually write our
breadth-first search let's do that right
now so breadth-first search is not a
recursive algorithm it's iterative so we
need a data structure to use for memory
so a queue is normally used for
breadth-first search so we want to mark
this position visit it as well so to
visit we're gonna add this cell that
we're about to use our traversal on our
c we're also going to add it to our
queue and so while our queue is not
empty that means we're gonna be
expanding our island so we're gonna pop
from the queue and we want to check the
adjacent positions of this position that
we just popped so the way I like to do
that is use a loop so we know that
there's four directions that we can go
in the direction to the right which is
one zero the direction to the left which
is negative one zero the direction above
zero one and the direction below
now for each of these directions we're
gonna check something first we want to
check that this position is in bounds
the way in Python I like to check that
is just if R Plus D R is in range of
rows and check that the column plus
direction that we're moving in is also
in range of columns and that this
position is a land position so this is
equal to 1 meaning its land and lastly
that this position hasn't already been
visited so if this is true then we can
add that to our queue because that means
we have to run breadth-first search on
this cell as well we also have to mark
it visited so we don't visit it twice
I noticed that we're doing this
computation a lot by adding row plus
different a direction of row so I'm
going to fix that really quickly
so that's a little bit cleaner and
that's pretty much the entire breadth
first search function it's gonna be
running until the queue is empty which
means that there's no more land
positions to visit I had a sloppy bug I
forgot to add this row column position
as a tuple which we want to do as a pair
not two elements separately I also use
the wrong function name for visit we
have to use visit add not append
because it's a set and on a list and
there is their breadth-first search
solution to this problem sorry about a
few of the bugs that i had oh that they
didn't trip you up too much and also the
neat thing about writing it this way is
if your interview asked you at the end
okay could you do a depth-first search
solution to this you can actually do it
really easily this pop left that we
wrote if you just change it to a regular
pop meaning a pop right it'll pop the
most recent element that we added
instead of the first element that we
added which means it'll basic b it'll
basically be a depth-first search but
it's non recursive it's iterative if you
enjoyed and if this was helpful please
leave a like and subscribe and thank you
for watching